Провідні західні політики привітали
Володимира Зеленського з перемогою,
не дочекавшись оголошення офіційних результатів
президентських виборів. Через кілька годин
після закриття дільниць йому зателефонували
президенти Польщі та Франції, а також президент США Дональд Трамп.
А канцлерка Німеччини Анґела Меркель вже навіть
запросила новообраного главу держави до Берліна.
Усе це свідчить про збереження підтримки України Заходом
попри зміну президента, зазначають оглядачі.
Успіх Володимира Зеленського в Європі
ще після першого туру оцінювали як ляпас правлячим елітам.
На думку опитаних DW експертів, українці
обрали Зеленського, бо розчаровані політиками
та невиконаними обіцянками Порошенка.
- Це демонстрація того, що значна частина
населення дійсно розчарована тим, що відбулося
за останні 5 років, попри проведені реформи.
- Люди хотіли більшого. Більше добробуту,
більше заходів боротьби з корупцією
у вищих ешелонах влади, а також перемир’я
на Донбасі. Вони цього не отримали і тому обрали іншого президента.
- Це був голос проти Порошенка, проти еліт загалом,
тому що українці ніколи не були задоволені владою.
Я думаю, на Зеленського чекає така ж доля.
З кожним днем його рейтинг падатиме.
Утім, закордонним партнерам все ще не до кінця
зрозуміло, чого насправді хоче Зеленський, і
чи зможе він ухвалювати самостійні рішення.
- Насправді Зеленський - така ж людина  системи,
заможна людина. У нього є зв'язки з олігархами,
передусім - з Ігорем Коломойським. Багато що
вказує на те, що ці зв'язки виходять за межі спільного бізнесу.
Зеленський - не проста людина з народу, в образі якої виступає в серіалі.
Скепсис щодо якісного оновлення української політики
за президентства Володимира Зеленського лунає
і на сторінках західної преси. Оглядачі впливової
німецької Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung
сумніваються, що Зеленський у нинішній ситуації
зможе керувати країною значно краще,
аніж Порошенко. Передовсім через брак політичного досвіду.
"До цього додаються й сумніви, чи не вимагатиме
олігарх Ігор Коломойський тепер щось взамін за те,
що його телеканал підтримував Зеленського.
Повернення політичного впливу Коломойського
було б поганою новиною для України".
Перед командою Зеленського гігантське завдання,
і тепер йому вже буде не до жартів, пише
французька Le Monde.
"Зламати систему", як це обіцяв кандидат,
під постійним тиском з боку Росії буде набагато складніше,
аніж здобути прихильність виборців.
Адже ця система тримається саме на слабкості
держави та її інститутів - єдиній зброї
в руках нового президента".
Тим часом у зовнішній політиці України
політологи суттєвих змін не очікують, оскільки
під час виборчих перегонів Зеленський
позиціонував себе як проєвропейський політик
і підкреслював незмінність курсу на вступ до ЄС та НАТО.
Водночас експерти визнають, що Євросоюзу
знадобиться час, аби перелаштуватися.
- Усі звикли працювати з Порошенком, і це відносно
добре вдавалося. А тепер не лише німецькій, але й
українській стороні треба буде звикати до нових умов.
У Зеленського дуже мало досвіду як у політиці в цілому,
так і в відносинах з Євросоюзом та Німеччиною.
Тому тепер на Заході намагатимуться
передусім з'ясувати, які позиції займе
новий український президент і з ким із його команди
можна буде конструктивно співпрацювати.